hey 42 here are you scared of wasps you
will be if you ever get chased by a
swarm of Asian giant Hornets they are
the world's largest Hornets at five
times the size of the European honeybee
they are nearly as big as your entire
form with a wingspan bigger than a
hummingbird's also known as the Japanese
giant Hornet they are responsible for
around 40 deaths every year in Japan
they will swarm and aggressively give
chase if you disturb their nest a single
sting is enough to kill a human even if
you're not allergic to Hornet venom one
victim described the sting as feeling
like a hot nail being driven into my leg
think giant wasps are deadly how about a
sea wasp that's the name given to the
Australian box jellyfish the box
jellyfish is the most venomous animal in
the world they have up to 60 tentacles
each 4.6 meters long each of its
tentacles has 5000 stinging cells and
enough venom to kill 60 humans its sting
will kill you in minutes by shutting
down your nervous system most victims
don't even make it back to shore scary
stuff but don't be fooled by the cone
snail the cone snail looks innocent with
its beautiful your innate shell but it's
a nasty little bugger a single drop of
venom from this underwater Menace is
enough to end 20 human lives inside its
shell is a poison dart that will
instantly harpoon you if you pick it up
once its venom is inside you it will
quickly paralyze your entire body then
you have about two hours to live there
is no anti-venom cone snails are found
in the oceans of tropical countries such
as Brazil a fever of spiders is
extremely common place but arachnophobic
scan relaxed because they may look
creepy but the fact is an extremely
small percentage of spider species
actually carry venom that is lethal to
humans even the infamous black widows
deadliness is a bit of a myth black
widow spiders aren't aggressive and very
rarely buy
but when they do the dose of toxins they
inject is usually not fatal to humans
however there is one spider you should
worry about more than any other the
Amazon rainforest is home to the world's
most dangerous spider the Brazilian
Wandering Spider it's awfully aggressive
and intensely venomous even though they
are smaller than most spider species
they're not afraid of humans
luckily they only inject a dose of venom
lethal to humans about 40 percent of the
time the rest of the time you will just
feel immense pain but these little
Horrors have a rather humorous but
unfortunate side effect males bitten by
The Wandering Spider will be afflicted
with a prolonged erection the spider's
venom has been called natural viagra
they're all terrifying animals but fishy
a number of kills none of these killers
come close to the biggest mass murderer
of all the mosquito mosquitoes are
responsible for between 2 to 3 million
human deaths every year mostly in Africa
their bites can transfer parasites that
carry malaria all very well but which
animal if it were you versus them one to
one would guarantee your death if it
attacks the prize goes to the brown bear
weighing in its 635 kilograms or 1,400
pounds the grizzly bear will be your
most formidable opponent it can kill you
with a single swipe of its pour there's
no use running there much faster than
you brown bears can reach speeds of 30
miles per hour
runners worldcom calculated you would
need a head start of 2146 meters
throughout run a brown bear if it chased
you
that's about 21 football pitches and
don't think you can escape up a tree or
dive into the nearest lake bears are
exceptional swimmers ountry climbers if
a brown bear decides you're its
breakfast you're its breakfast
luckily for us they don't attack humans
often especially not groups attacks on
groups of more than free are virtually
unheard of
so what truly is the most dangerous
animal well if there's one animal I
wouldn't want to get into a fight with
it's definitely the brown bear thanks
for watching until next time